coene au total plus de 29 mille cas
confirmés hier soir par le directeur de
la santé publique est presque 1700 morts
le confinement initialement prévu pour
deux semaines a été prolongée jusqu'au
15 avril prochain c'est en tout cas ce
qui a déclaré un tout à l'heure edouard
philippe les règles sont toujours les
mêmes simple et strictes à rester chez
vous sauf nécessité c'est à dire aller
faire les courses
elle se soigner ou encore aller un
travail etc
et parmi les nouvelles victimes july 16
ans a succombé cette semaine au
coronavirus elle est la plus jeune
victime du coronavirus sur le sol
français l'adolescente avait d'abord été
hospitalisée dans l'essonne avant d'être
transféré à l'hôpital necker à paris
retour sur les faits en images
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
[Musique]
et l'épidémie de coronavirus mais
l'industrie du tourisme en difficulté et
l'ensemble des stations balnéaires sont
touchés par les mesures de confinement
au pays basque comme partout sur le
littoral les commerces s'organisent pour
maintenir un minimum d'activités un
reportage sur le terrain de stéphanie
joire et robin pu l biarritz avance au
ralenti depuis l'annnonce du confinement
de la population le 16 mars dernier
la plupart des commerces de la ville ont
fermé leurs portes
n'ayant reçu aucune consigne
particulière à ce sujet un hôtel du
centre ville continue d'accueillir des
clients mais seulement cinq chambres sur
l'e25 disponible de l'établissement sont
occupés et la perte financière se fait
déjà ressentir par la direction depuis
le confinement on a continué un petit
peu a travaillé mon à une grosse sphère
d'activité effectivement puisqu'on a
perdu un peu plus de 4 millions de
réservations et donc été réservé mais
après le chaland qui passe et qui vient
de temps en temps ça c'est sûr que vu le
confinement n'a pas pu venir
et là sur le mois d'avril puisse
concerner ont fait on s'attend un mois
un mois blanc quasiment on a les
réservations toujours en stock mais qui
s'annulent au compte gouttes
donc on va avoir une paire truies
quasiment dix mille euros / mois d'avril
les halles de biarritz continue elle
aussi d'accueillir du public
ce centre de la vie économique locale
n'a pas fermé ses portes
malgré les annonces d'edouard philippe
le 23 mars dernier
le marché couvert a obtenu le maintien
de son activité par décret préfectoral
en contrepartie d'un renforcement des
mesures sanitaires
il ya des marquages au sol devant chaque
stand de façon à ce qu'ils y est les 1 m
de séparation
entre chaque individu on a demandé aux
fruits et légumes surtout ne pas avoir
les mains qui se balade des acheteurs
sur les fruits et légumes donc une
généralement ils ont mis du plastique
pour pour indiquer quand même le fait de
pas touchés et ce sont les commerçants
qui servent même les
les personnes avec un nombre de clients
limité à l'intérieur des halles
centrales les allées du marché sont
forcément un peu creux une situation
plutôt bien acceptée par les commerçants
et les habitués qui salue la décision de
maintenir l'ouverture du marché couvert
on est le poumon économique de biarritz
on a des personnes qui n'ont pas de
mobilité qui viennent une fois par
semaine faire leurs achats il faut
impérativement que l'on reste ouvert
c'est sûr qu'on fait pas les chiffres
d'affaires habituel mais on n'est pas là
non plus pour faire du sud à faire on
est là pour rendre service à tout le
monde et surtout rester ouverts à
trouver que tout ce qui est fait est
parfait et tout à fait dans la logique
des choses vont tout le monde le
respecte et au moins l'avantagé c'est
que si on respecte ses mesures de
sécurité
on peut accéder aux halles et continuer
à faire nos achats réguliers
c'est parfait à seulement quelques jours
du début de la saison touristique
la situation est de plus en plus
critique pour les commerçants qui mise
beaucoup sur le tourisme le prolongement
du confinement pourrait mettre en danger
de nombreuses activités à biarritz comme
partout ailleurs sur la côte basque
les syndicats sont en colère et
réclament aujourd'hui de meilleures
protections dont des masques pour les
salariés exposés aux convives 19 en
cause des cas confirmés dans plusieurs
secteurs d'activité une salariée de
carrefour à saint denis et un
intérimaire de manpower en mission chez
fedex à roissy sont morts lé syndicat
recense aujourd'hui et plus de 550 cas
supposé et 181 cas avérés dont plusieurs
graves dans la grande distribution
et en ces temps de confinement la
fermeture des établissements scolaires
risque elle aussi d'être prolongée le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
décidé en tout cas de maintenir cette
année le bac alors et en france si
voulez on est entre deux options entre
maintenir le bac tel quel
à la date prévue et puis avoir le
baccalauréat avec le contrôle continu
ce choix qui est en train de se dette
refait par plusieurs pays je me suis
engagé à ce qu'il y ait un baccalauréat
cette année donc
selon l'une ou l'autre de ces formules
mais il faut qu'il y ait un baccalauréat
on peut aussi imaginer des formules
intermédiaires je continue à écouter sur
ce point comme pour le brevet d'ailleurs
et je donnerai la réponse définitive
c'est à dire la solution que nous
retenons la semaine prochaine
probablement dans la deuxième moitié de
la semaine prochaine après avoir entendu
toutes les approches mais là aussi de
façon pragmatique de façon à ne laisser
aucun élève et aussi de garantir un
certain niveau de tous
c'est pourquoi la formule du contrôle
continu a aussi un intérêt parce qu'elle
nous permettrait d'avoir cours
plus loin dans le mois de juin parce que
vous savez souvent le mois de juin est
un peu avec des trous du fait de
l'organisation des examens
si on avait le contrôle continu on
aurait plus de temps pour avoir des
semaines de cours qui rattraperait les
semaines que nous perdons actuellement
et c'est un virage à 180 degrés que
prend le gouvernement concernant le
traitement à base d'hydroquinone rockin
elle défendue par le professeur raoul tu
es le premier ministre edouard philippe
et le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand ont signé un décret autorisant
la prescription de cette molécule pour
lutter contre la propagation du colis de
un décret a publié hier dans le journal
officiel qui encadre également la vente
du traitement pour éviter les ruptures
de stocks face à l'engouement suscité
par à la molécule de chloroquine et pour
jérôme marty médecin généraliste et
président de l'union française pour une
médecine libre la crau qui ne doit pas
être prescrite avec avec le consentement
des patients et avec un suivi médical
écouter notre rôle c'est d'expliquer
d'expliquer où on allait de ce
traitement d'expliquer et d un petit peu
de débrouiller le vrai du faux
il ya une excitation autour de 7 à terme
parce que il n'ya pas actuellement deux
traitements qui fonctionne
par rapport à cette pathologie vous le
savez on est très démuni c'est ce qui
crée un petit peu la peur et la psychose
ce traitement là semble avoir des
résultats il faut qu'on les tue 10 sur
des mesures d'aidé grosse cohorte de
patients mais on peut également s'y si
effectivement il est prescrit par des
médecins hospitaliers
ensuite le relayer en ville et en faire
profiter un certain nombre de patients
encore une fois sous surveillance et
avec leur consentement éclairé c'est à
dire en lorraine ayant expliqué à la
fois ce que cela peut mener et les
dangers que cela permet également en cas
de surdosage par exemple et à l'hôpital
de la pitié salpêtrière à paris le
personnel médical se serre les coudes
plus que jamais pour victoria le père
chef de clinique assistant d'un des
saisies en réanimation la cohésion est
le maître mot
en ces temps de crise alors pour
l'instant ça va
on est assez nombreux personne ne
l'équipe est malade pour l'instant on
est vraiment une cohésion d'équipé
extraordinaire et j'ai moi
personnellement je pense que j'ai
vraiment la chance d'avoir une équipe
comme ça on sert vraiment les coudes et
on discute beaucoup étaient qu'il ya un
problème dès qu'il ya une émotion un peu
difficile on en parle on garde rien pour
nous et il ya une hostie une psychologue
dans le service et auxquels on peut
faire appel si jamais ça va vraiment pas
il ya des situations vraiment compliqué
des malades c'est une situation
extraordinaire actuellement c'est
difficile mais avec l'équipe avec le
soutien qu'on a entre nous ça va edouard
philippe vient d'annoncer la
prolongation des mesures de confinement
jusqu'au 15 avril prochain en moins l
épidémie de coronavirus continue sa
progression sur le sol français je vous
propose d'écouter est justement le
premier ministre le renouvellement de la
période de confinement pour deux
semaines supplémentaires à compter de
mardi prochain soit jusqu'au mercredi 15
avril les mêmes règles que celles
actuellement en vigueur continueront à
s'appliquer cette période pourra
évidemment être prolongée si la
situation sanitaire l'exigé
si et seulement si la situation
sanitaire l'exigent
vous savez que le conseil scientifique
qui éclairent les décisions du
gouvernement évalue à au moins six
semaines au global la période totale de
confinement il est encore trop tôt pour
le savoir avec certitude c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'annonce cette décision
une première en europe hier en france à
20 malades ont été transportés dans un
train médicalisé ce tgv en provenance de
strasbourg avait pour terminus la ville
de nantes afin de soulager les hôpitaux
de la région grand est fortement impacté
par le nouveau coronavirus au total ce
sont pas moins de quatre centres
hospitaliers de l'ouest de la france qui
ont accueilli les malades notamment à
les hôpitaux dangers du monde la roche
sur yon et de nantes
selon le fmi l'économie mondiale est
clairement entré en récession l'urgence
économique causée par l'épidémie de kobe
19 ne suffit pourtant pas à gommer les
dissensions au sein de l'union
européenne quatre pays européens dont
l'allemagne se sont fermement opposés à
l'émission de corona bond des
obligations communes à l'ensemble de la
zone euro un mécanisme destiné à lutter
contre la crise économique engendrée par
le corona virus en mutualisant les
futures dettes contractées par les
différents membres de l'union européenne
une mesure demandée par plusieurs pays
dont l'italie et l'espagne ainsi que la
france et l'allemagne tout comme
l'autriche les pays bas et la finlande
ont refusé en lui préférant le mécanisme
européen de stabilité et pour parler de
cette situation économique au sein de
l'union européenne nous sommes avec
olivier delamarche économiste membre
fondateur d econoclaste et experts dans
l'émission c'est cash que vous pouvez
retrouver sur rt france
bonjour olivier delamarche merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
alors on l'a dit les allemands avaient
déjà refusé les eurobonds en 2011 comme
les français d'ailleurs à l'époque et
pour lutter contre la crise économique
pourquoi cette inflexibilité de la part
de berlin alors que paris lui a changé
son fusil d'épaulé parce que ça sert à
rien ça montre simplement la fébrilité
de certains pays qui sont face à des des
gérants dont notre ministre de
l'économie 1 et d'autres qui sont dans
une situation compliquée on a pas de
croissance ça fait un moment en étant en
récession on a une dette qui enfle 1 et
est donc ont paniqué on essaie de de se
dire ah bah on va aller voir nos petits
camarades européens qui eux gèrent mieux
leur pays comme l'autriche ou comme
l'allemagne depuis un bon moment et on
va essayer de faire passer soit un
eurobond il ya quelques il ya quelques
temps et puis cette fois ci le corps en
abondent
et puis cette fois ci ça va peut-être
marcher parce que comme tout le monde
est touché par le le corps navires us
des fois que ça marcherait sur un
malentendu banon ça marche encore pas
sur un malentendu et on voit justement
toute la solidarité et ce fameux couple
franco-allemand couple qui m'a l'air
quand même en grand divorce depuis
depuis un bout de temps donc voilà tant
mieux on va se dire peut-être que le
coronavirus finira par faire entrer dans
la tête de certains que l'union
européenne n'existe pas est une vaste
blague
pourquoi olivier delamarche préféré le
mécanisme européen de stabilité parce
que ils se disent que toute façon
que lit ne l'utiliseront pas plus je
crois si vous voulez le problème c'est
que là on est en train de voir
on est en train de voir des gens qui
panique que ce soit les banques
centrales que ce soit les ministres des
différents pays
ils savent pas très bien comment s'en
sortir ici ceux qui vont être face à une
récession comme on en a jamais vu jamais
c'est à dire qu'on n'a jamais eue
même en temps de guerre on n'a jamais eu
des pays complètement à l'arrêt et puis
pas un pays tous les pays
donc évidemment que ça va faire des
dégâts comme on n'arrive même pas à les
imaginer
et là dessus on arrive avec surtout des
pays kinky sont loin d'avoir fait du
gras en en disant si vous laissiez
encore on avait refait du gras si encore
on avait eu des rémunérations en hausse
et c'est que les gens avaient refait de
l'epargne que les sociétés s'était
refait de la trésorerie mais c'est pas
le cas du tout hélas aujourd'hui on se
retrouve complètement démunis parce que
je vous rappelle que depuis 2008 les
états ont pris sur leur dos une bonne
partie des dettes qu'ils étaient des
dettes bancaires des dettes privées et
donc aujourd'hui on est à bloc donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que on va
faire tous comme les japonais c'est à
dire qu'on va se retrouver tous avec 200
250 % dette par rapport au pib mais on y
va
on y va on y va on se console japonisme
que ce soit par les banques centrales
qui se met à tout acheter et à et à
faire tourner la planche à billets comme
on l'a jamais fait tourner jusqu'à
présent et puis avec les gouvernements
qui sont prêts là cette fois ci à faire
des chèques alors c'est des chèques sans
provision malheureusement mais son
déchet quand même à qui mieux mieux le
problème si vous voulez ce qu'on peut
voir quand même ce qu'on peut constater
c'est que quand la grèce avait des
problèmes quand l'italie était en train
de faire ta y quand la le portugal
faisait faillite
j'ai pas l'impression que on est sorti
nos chantiers à ce moment là et que ce
soit à carnet ouvert qu'on est sorti des
bd montant pareil donc visiblement le
petit virus fait peur beaucoup plus que
les l'écroulement de l'économie grecque
ou italienne et et là on se met à faire
des chèques n'importe comment c'est à
dire qu'on est vraiment dans une dans
une situation où on fait des chèques
sans provisions on promet des choses
qu'on sera bien incapable de tenir
et voilà donc je pense pas franchement
que la nouvelle soit bonne ça ne
m'étonne pas qu'ils est ressorti ce
vieux nanar de 2,2 euros bond à la sauce
cornaz et puis mais bon on s'aperçoit
que c'est c'est à chaque fois un refus
de pays qui sont un petit peu plus un
petit peu plus intelligent et qui savent
très bien que toute façon quand on fait
une dette comme ça il va falloir un jour
là remboursés et que ça pose déjà des
problèmes de rembourser et celles qui
sont présents pour pas s'en remettre une
sur le dos
en plus vous avez des gens qui
aujourd'hui sont en train d'utiliser
leur trésorerie pour vivre pour vivre
uniquement donc ça m'étonnerait beaucoup
qu'il y ait beaucoup de candidats à
souscrire à ce genre d'obligation
merci beaucoup olivier delamarche
d'avoir été avec nous cet après midi sur
rt frange rappelle un que vous êtes
économiste membre fondateur d
econoclaste est que nos téléspectateurs
peuvent vous retrouver sur arte france
sur cette chaîne dans l'émission effet
cash merci beaucoup
à bientôt à boris johnson a été testé
positif aux coronavirus après avoir
présenté de légers symptômes hier selon
downing street le premier ministre
britannique a pris la parole sur les
réseaux sociaux il indique être en auto
isolement et qu'il compte continuer à
gérer la crise lui qui est venu yves
mans critiqué pour avoir tardé à prendre
des mesures contre la pandémie
[Musique]
je voulais vous mettre au courant d'une
chose qui est arrivé aujourd'hui j'ai
développé certains symptômes du
coronavirus c'est à dire de la fièvre et
une toux persistante sur les conseils du
médecin en chef j'ai effectué le test
qui s'est révélé positif
donc je travaille depuis chez moi je
m'isole ce qui est exactement la chose à
faire mais n'ayez aucun doute que je
continue grâce aux technologies à
communiquer avec toute mon équipe pour
mener la nation dans ce combat contre le
coronavirus l'italie est aujourd'hui
fille centre européen de l'épidémie
d'après le président de l'institut
supérieur de santé le pays pourrait
atteindre dans les prochains jours elle
le pic de l'épidémie de kobe 19 l'italie
compte près de huit mille deux cents
décès en plus et 80000 personnes déjà
touchées par la maladie certains
sont hospitalisés parfois dans un état
grave malgré ces chiffres la progression
de l'épidémie semble légèrement ralentir
est de son côté le premier ministre
italien giuseppe comté a refusé le
projet d'un sommet de l'union européenne
censé trouver une réponse économique à
la crise du coronavirus et en espagne le
nombre de morts dépasse désormais les
4800 à 769 personnes sont décédées en
seulement 24 heures à le nombre de cas
de contamination s'est lui aussi envolé
ces derniers jours l espagne et compte
désormais plus de 64 mille cas dépistés
elle ce qui en fait le quatrième pays le
plus touché dans le monde le
gouvernement a décidé de prolonger le
confinement est les espagnols sont
invités à rester chez eux jusqu'au 14
avril prochain au moins
elokobi de 19 propage également en
russie plus de 1000 personnes infectées
et trois morts elles sont à déplorer
selon le dernier bilan officiel des
autorités russes
s il n'y a pas de confinement russie
vladimir poutine a annoncé hier une
semaine chômé avec paiement des salaires
le vote populaire sur la réforme
constitutionnelle est quant à lui
reporté pour évoquer la situation en
russie le point avec notre correspondant
à moscou en train de clairon pour la
première fois le nombre de cas confirmés
a dépassé la barre des 1000 milles 36
pour être exact selon le dernier
décompte avec près de 200 nouveaux cas
ces dernières 24 heures et c'est
toujours moscou qui on concentre qui en
concentrent la majorité avec 503 cas
comptabilisés un porte-parole du kremlin
a d'ailleurs fait savoir qu'elle
employés de l'administration
présidentielle avaient été contaminés le
bilan humain officiel quant à lui
s'élève à 3 morts tandis qu'au total 20
45 personnes ont guéri et ont pu rentrer
chez elle depuis le début de la pandémie
je rappelle qu'à compter d'aujourd'hui
tous les vols internationaux depuis et
vers la russie sont suspendus seuls les
avions qui ramait des citoyens russes
bloqués à l'étranger sont autorisés de
cette façon ces tous derniers jours par
mois de cinquante trois mille personnes
ont pu être rapatriés et à la suite de
l'adresse de vladimir poutine de ce
mercredi
tous les cafés et restaurants ferment
leurs portes dès demain samedi les
mesures les plus restrictifs jusqu'à
l'imposer uniquement à mossoul monte
également
m
étendu je vous propose d'écouter sur ce
sujet le premier ministre russe vous
savez que la semaine prochaine a été
déclarée semaines de congés par le
président à cet égard j'estime
nécessaire d'étendre à toutes les
régions de notre pays
les mesures restrictives déjà prise à
moscou et dans la région de moscou
il s'agit tout d'abord du secteur des
loisirs et des divertissements
ces décisions sont évidemment dur et je
voudrais m'adresser à tous les citoyens
de notre pays
prenez au sérieux et agissez de manière
responsable
maintenant si tu estimes soyouz et pour
limiter les déplacements à l'intérieur
du territoire russe le gouvernement
suspend les réservations et
l'hébergement dans le centre de loisirs
les centres de santé et autres
sanatorium jusqu'au 1er juin 2001 avec
toutes ces mesures successives
on se rapproche donc dans les faits de
plus en plus au scénario de confinement
actuellement en vigueur en france
les etats-unis sont devenus cette nuit
le pays le plus touché par la pandémie
du coronavirus avec près à 2,86 milka et
près de 1300 morts selon l'université
d'hopkins est les etats-unis dépasse
désormais la chine et l'italie en nombre
de cas pourtant hier après un entretien
téléphonique avec emmanuel macron le
président américain a laissé présager un
allègement des mesures de distanciation
sociale nous devons nous remettre au
travail
notre peuple veut travailler ils veulent
retourner au travail
il doit d'y retourner nous allons parler
de date
nous allons parler avec beaucoup de
grands professionnels mais ce pays a été
construit sur la base du travail
notre peuple veut retourner travailler
je l'entends aux efforts de la part de
tout le monde
nous verrons bien ce qui se passera nous
aurons beaucoup plus d'informations au
début de la semaine prochaine
la situation est très préoccupante avec
une progression terrain très rapide de
la pandémie en afrique un cri d'alarmé
lancé aujourd'hui dans les médias par la
directrice afrique de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé l'afrique du sud
est particulièrement inquiète avec les
deux premiers morts enregistrés dans la
région du cap et la barre à d'humilier
contaminé dépasser le pays est désormais
en confinement en national
explications de walid bennani et
cyrielle beauvais johannesburg théâtre
d'une scène inédite face au président
sud africain des militaires chante et
acclament leur chef d'état
pourtant malgré cette liesse apparente
la situation devient critique en afrique
du sud
notre pays n'a jamais traversé une
période comme celle ci c'est sans
précédent non seulement dans notre
démocratie mais aussi dans l'histoire de
notre pays
ce qu'on finit pendant 21 jours pour
aller faire la guerre à un ennemi
invisible le coronavirus
le pays a ainsi rejoint les 3 milliards
de personnes dans le monde déjà appelés
à rester chez elle
premier pays d'afrique à imposer le
confinement total l'afrique du sud
s'appuie sur le soutien de l'armée pour
assurer son application un confinement
qui vient renforcer les dernières
mesures drastiques prises par le
gouvernement
vente d'alcool et de cigarettes prohibée
tout comme promener son chien
seul l'achat des produits de première
nécessité est autorisée être obligé de
se confiner est un problème plus aucune
bon mais je pense que c'est surtout pour
contenir le virus qui se propage dans le
pays
c'est très triste surtout pour les gens
qui vivent au jour le jour
j'ai l'autorisation d'aller travailler
mais cela a été un processus très
difficile
[Musique]
c'est une
nous allons travailler pour certains
d'entre nous et nous mettons nos vies en
danger
mais au bout du compte il ya des gens
qui ont besoin de nos services et le
président fait ce qu'il a dit il n'y a
pas d'autre choix que de contrôler le
pays de cette façon car la population
sait qu'elle doit avoir une vie après
cela quand certains continuent d'aller
travailler
d'autres ont choisi de se mettre à
l'abri en famille un exode étroitement
surveillés par les personnels soignants
nous faisons juste un test kovy 19 juste
pour vérifier si vous allez bien si vous
avez besoin d aide si nous pouvons vous
en voyez faire des tests des choses
comme ça ce que nous cherchons c'est de
savoir d'où vous venez
où vous allez si vous avez été en
contact avec quelqu'un que vous
connaîtriez qui a le coc vite 19 une
mesure de confinement total qui risque
de bouleverser l'organisation du pays
le gouvernement exige l'appliquer
partout y compris dans les bidonvilles
très nombreux en afrique du sud les sud
africains redoutent les ravages du
nouveau coronavirus si l'épidémie
prolifèrent dans ces quartiers déjà
fortement touchée par le vih et la
tuberculose
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
beaucoup de l'avoir suivi prochain point
sur l'actualité et dans un peu plus de
trente minutes en compagnie de magali
forestier restez chez vous et avec nous
sur arte france
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité mais idée courageuse
des mots qui comptent la haine en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus
extrêmes
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview